Okay, I'm going to try my, my little
friend on the right here. And, okay, validation rules.
>> Yup.
>> Excellent, new. Okay, rule name, I want
to call this, Valid Ticket Number Checker. How's that?
>> It's a little weird, but.
>> Valid ticket number?
>> Let's run with it. There you go.
[LAUGH]
>> in description make sure that you've got less than eight tickets.
>> Yeah, and I mean, while we're checking, you know, bad data, why don't
we just make sure there's also more than zero tickets. So at least one ticket.
>> Okay, that makes sense. And, you've bought at least one ticket.
>> So the weird thing about validation
rules is they're a little backwards. The
rule that you create needs to check if the formula is true, which means
whatever equation you're building needs to evaluate to
true in order to throw an error message.
>> So basically, I want to say, instead
of saying, making sure, make sure it's between
one and eight. I want to make sure it's not less than one or greater than eight.
>> Exactly.
>> That makes, I mean sort of makes sense, but I'll roll
with it. Okay, so I guess I'm going to use this little hierarchy thing.
>> It
allows you to choose fields on the attendee object, or even of of related
objects. But yeah, just click the fields
that you're trying to add into this formula.
>> Tickets purchased, I think.
>> Yep.
>> Okay, so I'm going to make sure, I
want to check if tickets purchased is greater than eight.
>> Yep.
>> I can just do that, right?
>> I want to do or, how do I do or?
>> Check that insert operator.
>> Oh, sweet. Okay.
Or tickets purchased, less than one.
>> Right.
>> Okay, I'm going to check to make sure I didn't screw anything up too bad.
>> And this looks pretty similar to the formula we just made doesn't it?
>> Yeah, yeah. It's cool that you can do all this
with just the mouse. Okay, no errors found. Okay, error message. Dude.
You have to buy between 1 and 8 tickets. Okay,
Save. Okay. I'm going to, obviously, try and break this rule now.
>> So, let's create a new one. New attendee. Maybe, Sally Scalper?
>> Oh, nice. Sally Scalper, you're not getting in through my validation rule.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> Email, thief@evil.whatever. purchase source, box office. If
she'll try to buy general admission tickets, she'll try to buy ten of them, for
Cloudstock. And let's to see what happens to Sally Scalper.
Ha, she was foiled, she was thwarted in her evil attempts to scalp tickets.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> Okay, that's pretty cool.
>>
[LAUGH].
>> Alright, Sam this is pretty cool, we did all of
this object building and field adding, and things are updating automatically.
>> Formulas, validation, like does your head feel like it's about to explode?
>> No, no. It's actually, it's alright.
>> That's awesome.
>> Which, I mean, so we've only done it for attendees and festivals. I
guess next step is to do it with bands and stages and all that.
>> Yeah! Let's do it!